you have seven movies coming out yeah
yes good for you translations that are
very nice you know it just occurred to
me you've done more movies this year
almost in the number of kids you have
you have five kids I have five kids I
should clarify the seven movies they're
porn very good in them yes yes sorry
kids
can you believe it and it's like I mean
that's why I look like this five kids
and it's just a you know something I
regret
really I mean there's there's too many
of them there's too many of them there's
way to make sometimes a dinner I just
pretend I'm hosting a reality show
called so you think you're going to
college if I'm getting that boat you
know so wait so do you look around the
table and and and it's just week that's
all that's five no one even does that
anymore we I grew up I was one of six
yes I always before and you were one of
six but now like two kids that's about
it
yeah cuz people are smarter it's just I
mean it is fascinating I mean they're
all kind of different versions of me and
my wife my youngest looks exactly like
me which is kind of fun and he's very
grumpy he's always in a bad mood and I
thought that was kind of cute until
everyone was like oh he's just like you
always in a bad mood I'm not always in a
bad mood and they're like you are like
so that's how I learned that I'm a
bastard
[Laughter]